City bus and transit riders got a lifeline
in the latest pandemic related relief bill
New York City's subway system will get
billions, though much less than it asks for
Don't think of this as a bailout to the profligate.
The aid begins to correct for an historic inequity
The federal government has long been subsidizing
our least efficient systems in rural and small
town America, and neglecting cities. Transit aidin a time of crisis should not reward cities for
decades of fiscal mismanagement, but should helpthem get past COVID and chart a path to stability
New York's is the most used public transit
system in the U.S. and typically does not
rely on any federal help to run the system. Nowcompare it to Oneida in upstate New York.
Currently the Big Apple has lost most of its subwayriders and fares. Congress filling that gap
is necessary and timely, lest cities be robbedof the ability to rebound. Any post-pandemic
aid should require that they economize, but when
it comes to transit cities should no longer be
disfavored.
Do you think big cities should get
more federal transit aid? Let us know in our poll
Also, let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds. And be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI